i think men in general could take double
standards i think it's the lack of
appreciation for me taking the double
standards like it's like you expect me
to do it like it's like
like a thank you would help solve a lot
of men's issues if if women said thank
you to men i appreciate you big man do
you know what i'm saying i appreciate it
that alone i have i haven't heard for
the last five years women do you think
men are not appreciated
i mean they appreciate about no no i'm
in women okay i i think they could be
appreciated more
so then that's the no then men are not
appreciated i don't think they're
unappreciated but i think say in terms
of society
sorry and i know in terms of society
like i would say
alex um
i say when i say society i mean like job
roles like normally for me i don't know
like but men are normally favored for
things
so i think because men are favored
i don't know women have that little mmm
about things you think women are angry
at men nowadays
a little yeah because i think
like going back to traditions women were
expected to be a certain way and they
don't want to fit in a box anymore i
think they do want to be themselves and
i think now women are finding that i
like i think you touched on it earlier
like they're taking away a man's stance
so like they can provide for themselves
so like like what am i going to do for
you but i think
then you need to find a different
balance in your relationship
for me
if i'm looking for a partner
i'd want them to be equal to me equal or
yeah of course it'd be nice if they're
like above but i'd want someone just the
same as me like i don't want it
ambition wise like the same goals
earning similar money or we want to do
the same thing that you just need to
have like
be on just on the same path like just do
you believe that there's equality
like do you really believe men and women
are equal no
you don't why not i think it differs in
each aspect as well like it will be
different in a workplace it'll be
different in a relationship when it
comes to sex it's different in like in
all of like and more there's so many
doubles do you think things are now
heavily skewed in women's direction or
men's direction
i'd say women because we fought for it
but it doesn't mean that men are
unimportant like i think men
don't think that's why men are angry
i could hear that but it's also nice
that i think how women have found their
independence and stuff like the
persona and
like thing that society have put on men
of like having to be strong and a
provider like it's your time to to take
that time for you
and like work on those other things like
you don't have to be a provider or you
don't have to be that yeah that might be
what society has but why can't you
connect your emotions a man that's not a
provider doesn't get much play in the
society
for you to say that like he doesn't get
much play and
um
i hear i i hear it but i think it's
because when we talk about i'm just so
not that person
like i just don't it's just not really
like so you wouldn't want your man to be
the provider
like it'd be nice yeah but as long as
i've got myself it'd be nice but as long
as i've got myself i don't expect that
from you
like i i so you would be provided in a
relationship
long as i can cover me and you can cover
you like nobody
go on but like you're saying like okay
initially the issue starts off with it
would be nice but then you said as long
as you can cover you
and
he can cover him but i think what you
don't realize is a provider someone who
covers both yeah no i know but i'm like
i'm just saying when you're coming into
a partnership you're both two individual
people you create one bond but you both
have to bring something to it that's all
i'm saying
so
do uh women are you okay with being the
provider no i want the management
provider
i kind of want it to be more even
but then if if women okay so if as a
woman you had a man who was equal to you
providing or you were his provider um
would you respect him the same way
yeah we're people we're humans it's not
about man we're not against each other
guys guys are they going to respect you
the same way do you think hell nah like
maybe things that can slide now that
won't be able to slide how long how long
she's going to respect you for
a day until until infatuation
i mean until infatuation ends and that's
it like she she monkey branches to
another person i feel like she'll
provide for me until tyrell from down
the street he's like six foot nine with
like
yeah 45k in his bank comes along and
steals it from me i don't know about 45k
but yeah no i don't i don't think women
um
i think
i think a lot of the time that there may
be women
that will be okay with being provider
there are some women that are but i
think generally women want to be
provided for yeah
i think the difference in that is if the
guy isn't going to be the provider and
say this is where the more partnership
relation like obviously a marriage is a
partnership but on the sense of oh we're
going to split everything and not 50 50
but a balance between it so if you're
not like covering it and we're both like
doing the parts then i'm not going to be
doing all the housework i'm not like
because if the guy is providing then
okay sure that's fine to say oh will you
take care of the house like i'm gonna
provide the house and you take care of
the house but if we're both going in
together i'm not taking care of the
house and you're not taking care of the
house like if we're both providing for
the house we're both taking care of the
house and i think that's the big
difference okay so this this how my mom
always said it to me yeah like in terms
of this
well not to me but to my sisters
you're gonna clean your house anyway
even if i wasn't there you're going to
cook food for yourself anyway
so all you need to do now is just put
one extra
cup of rice in there so what were you
going to do here by yourself in terms of
uber
you're not going to cook
i would uber
i'll cook for myself once in a while and
then by uber the rest or go out
and guess what i will i will clean half
of the time and you can uber that [ __ ]
the other time but then you're going to
be in a dirty house no you're good you
will be there too
like it's not just one person yeah he's
very obtuse and like
rude to say oh yeah i'm you should just
be doing this if you're providing then
it makes sense to say okay this is your
part like we're we're paying we're
playing equal parts even though one is
costing more and one why don't we with
mon like money and won't be with time
but in that sense you're working
together if we're both splitting it no
i'm not doing your chores for you like
we're both gonna split because the same
way you're saying you would do this by
yourself
so would you okay i said this i said
this earlier but i'm gonna say it again
if the burglar comes in the house are we
gonna share the responsibilities
no that's on you bro it's on me right
you're gonna hide behind me right how
often is someone yeah exactly in your
house okay that's not the point i'm just
obviously
i mean that's my point
like but you know what i mean there's
responsibilities that i have to take on
whether or not i like it or not
i mean am i lying
you name them you you okay like you said
protector and provider means protector
so if you have a home together or you
have children or you have a business
he's
as a man supposed to protect that i
think women expect men to protect
and if a man doesn't protect for
instance the burglar you don't see him
the same
you're going to see that man as weak
you're going to you're going to probably
want to go for somebody who is more of a
protector
yeah and like but which is to be
expected like i'm not saying that i'm
not gonna
i'm not gonna do it but i'm just saying
like again you've taken
it for granted like
i'm risking my life to save you like my
life
like you you can't clean up are you not
saving yourself as well
no not necessarily because i could jump
out the window and leave you there do
you know what i mean
i could run faster than you i could jump
higher than you i'd um trust me if if
it's between me and you you'll be the
one that's getting hurt if i wanted to
i think it's also important to
understand in a relationship or a
healthy relationship um
what men and women have is like two
different roles and men a woman's role
would be to be submissive but only if
the man is willing to die for her
so
people get that kind of misconstrued and
when like a man's demanding a woman to
be submissive
the question is really like if
ever you were in a situation
where you had to put your life at risk
for her would you do it and it's at that
moment you can really kind of do
about you you've got
it's men that you have to remember i
said again men is the one that decides
on a relationship now do you want a
relationship now where your woman pays
half and now when you come back from
work you both got to clean you both go
you both got golden industry you know
you've got to do this no you you
dedicate which person does which which
person does which